bienvenue à la facture le coeur d'une
voiture électrique c'est son énorme
batterie très puissante et qui coûte
aussi très cher voici l'histoire d'une
utilisatrice qui a découvert une
particularité dans la batterie de sa
Smart qui n'est pas Smart du tout
[Musique]
en 2021 Lucette se procure sa toute
première voiture entièrement électrique
une Smart Fortwo 2014 du constructeur
Mercedes Benz cette petite marque là je
l'ai acheté parce que on fait pas de
pollution ça coûte pas cher ou avec ça
parce que on peut la brancher chez nous
puis je me disais mais ce serait bien
une petite voiture ça serait cute me
promener avec ça elle paie plus de 9000
dollars pour sa Smart électrique acheté
chez un concessionnaire d'occasion deux
mois plus tard ces ennuis commencent le
haut-parleur puis le clignotant gauche
et finalement le verrouillage à distance
cesse de fonctionner peu de temps après
rien ne va plus belle la voiture refusée
de partir le matin moi ça me dérange pas
tellement parce que j'ai une RAV4
[Musique]
la Smart est immobilisée pendant environ
trois mois dans son stationnement
Lucette consulte deux garages de sa
région et contactent également un
concessionnaire Mercedes ses factures de
remorquage et de diagnostic s'élève à
plus de 3000 dollars ça c'est votre
remorquage ici on n'est pas
remarquer quatre fois
insatisfaite des réponses obtenues et
des solutions proposées elle fait
remorquer sa Smart à 150 km de chez elle
chez un expert qui aime bien mauvaise
nouvelle à lui apprendre
[Musique]
la batterie était drainé complètement ce
qui leur a impossible à réparer on ne
peut pas réutiliser les cellules telles
qu'elles sont là ça aurait été dangereux
comme les autres voitures électriques la
Smart de Lucette add possède une grosse
batterie haute tension qui fait bouger
le véhicule et une petite de 12 volts
pour les accessoires or dans le cas de
la Smart Fortwo électrique la petite
peut avoir des effets dramatiques sur la
grosse qui elle coûte une fortune plus
de 30000 dollars pour une batterie neuve
si la batterie 12 volts se décharge
après un certain temps on va enclencher
un mode qui va vider la batterie 400
volts donc la batterie de traction c'est
là qu'elle va se mettre en mode Ferrari
ailleurs qu'on peut dire en français sur
plusieurs semaines pour on va dire la
scrapper la décharger complètement à
zéro la rendre inerte ce que ça donne
finalement c'est qu'une batterie qui est
perte totale on peut pas la réutiliser
d'aucune manière ma petite Smart je
réalise que s'autodétruisait je l'ai
laissé trop longtemps rien faire
Guillaume André dit avoir vu une dizaine
de Smart électrique terrassés par le
même problème à tel point qu'il en a
fait le sujet d'une chronique vidéo
historait longtemps ok la batterie 400
volts va se décharger complètement puis
là il va se mettre en junky hard mode
Junker mode en français
dépotoires c'est l'expression utilisée
par les amateurs de Smart et des experts
comme Daniel Breton PDG d'une
association vouée à l'électrification
des transports nous le rencontrons au
salon du véhicule électrique de
Saint-Hyacinthe la petite batterie 12
volts
l'ordinateur de bord lui enregistre un
message bon ben ça doit être parce que
le véhicule est au dépatoires parce que
probablement plus de batterie à bord du
véhicule donc on va vider la grosse
batterie pour des raisons de sécurité
c'est le Junker mode ou le mode
dépotoires j'imagine qui ont voulu
développer ça parce qu'il disait ben on
veut s'assurer que les voitures et les
batteries sont gérées de façon
sécuritaire lorsqu'elles sont radio
dépotoir mais ils ont oublié où ils ont
pas pensé au fait que si en Europe les
gens n'entreposent pas le véhicule en
Amérique du Nord il y a beaucoup de gens
qui le font c'est un vrai problème pour
des gens qui ont du mal electric drive
selon plusieurs experts aucun autre
modèle véhicule électrique même si
immobilisé et non rechargée pendant
plusieurs mois ne se retrouvera avec une
batterie haute tension hors d'usage
heureusement il y a aucun autre
constructeur qui a mis en place un
système c'est certain que le parc
automobile de la Smart Fortwo électrique
et marginal mais en 2021 on en comptait
tout de même un peu plus de 650
immatriculées au Québec dont celle de
Martin Boisvert administrateur du groupe
facebook club Smart Québec moi j'ai
découvert l'existence du John cardmode
parce que je suis sur plusieurs forums à
travers le monde j'ai pas appris ça de
Mercedes c'est pas quelque chose qui est
documenté dans les dans les manuels du
propriétaire j'ai eu l'occasion de lire
le manuel du propriétaire une coupe de
foi à cause des problèmes que j'avais
et puis il y a personne qui m'a informé
de ça même les concessionnaires Mercedes
semblent peu ou pas au courant du
problème oui bonjour est-ce que je
pourrais parler un aviseur technique
s'il vous plaît nous en contactons une
dizaine au Québec en prétendant être
propriétaire d'une Smart électrique la
majorité nous disent n'avoir jamais
entendu parler du phénomène non je
connais pas ça le Junker
vous avez jamais entendu parler de ça
pour Charles Tanguy porte-parole de
l'Office de la protection du
consommateur du Québec ces
problématiques bon d'abord la Loi sur la
protection du consommateur interdit à
tout commerçant ou fabricant de passer
sous silence un fait important donc
omettre d'informer le consommateur d'une
chose comme celle-ci c'est en soi une
infraction
publique de Mercedes Mercedes Benz a
refusé nos demandes d'entrevue
l'entreprise nous renvoie au manuel du
conducteur et précise qu'il faut
remplacer la batterie 12 volts au moins
une fois ou trois ans et qu'il ne faut
jamais laisser le véhicule presque ou
totalement déchargé plus de 14 jours
mais Mercedes dit ne pas être familier
avec le mode junkyrd il en est pourtant
question sur des sites de discussion
d'amateurs de Smart faute d'information
officielle le mystère persiste
on n'a pas accès à l'information que
Mercedes programmé ça on sait que ça
arrive après un certain temps c'est pas
du jour au lendemain que la batterie 12
volts est morte là on pense plusieurs
mois que là le mode de va s'enclencher
selon Guillaume André si le problème est
pris à temps il est possible de sauver
la batterie haute tension mais dans le
cas de Lucette il était tout simplement
trop tard dans son cas la seule solution
était de lui offrir une batterie
usagée d'environ 5000 dollars plus main
d'oeuvre donc on parlait entre 7000
dollars le pour une réparation pour une
voiture j'avais payé 9000 dollars un
instant là
ça me fait toujours un petit quelque
chose d'entendre quelqu'un qui a une
mauvaise expérience avec sa Smart alors
que au niveau fiabilité c'est les Smart
les plus fiables notre cas moi que j'ai
à date c'est celle que j'ai eu le moins
de problèmes avec
a finalement vendu sa voiture a vécu
l'électrique Simon André pour 1500$
elle préfère aujourd'hui en rire plutôt
qu'en pleurer aujourd'hui j'en suis
revenue mais un moment donné je suis
venue belle écœurer de tout
[Rires]
comme on dit c'est pas parce qu'on rit
que c'est drôle à notre connaissance au
moins une autre personne a poursuivi
merci Mercedes Canada à la Cour des
petites créances pour exactement le même
problème et la poursuite c'est soldé par
une entente à l'amiable